i have a follow-up question would you
guys
be open to an open relationship where
the guy can step out from time to time
but it's just it's just sex there's no
no no no no no no but listen listen
listen wait wait but
okay but but all of your bills are
taking care of the rest of your life you
don't have to work you can get like
whatever you want you can have as many
kids as you want like you
the rest of your life you're good you
just have to deal with him stepping out
from time to time
you put up a
heartbeat right in there pearl no go
ahead
um you know i would love love to say
that i would but knowing myself and the
green monster that is in me
i am a jealous [ __ ]
so
you know like if i i mean
you might you might kill the girl i
might no i might kill the man
i would just be like you know like
i don't know like like why
could you do it and why could i not
because you don't have to pay like
that's the trade-off is is he's saying
you get all my resources you don't have
to work so i get to cheat that's that's
the i might as well just have a sugar
daddy at that point what that's like
well you're the only one that gets his
emotional commitment so all the other
girls they're just like
just physical he doesn't really cause
men you know they can sleep with a girl
and not care about her yeah yeah i'm
sorry for me it's gonna be an absolutely
not looking right at the camera so you'd
rather you'd rather so you'd rather work
the rest of your life and just have a
guy that's loyal i mean i would i do not
want to
i would actually love to be working the
rest of my life like i don't i feel like
if i weren't then i'd just be like
you know i mean like nothing against
housewives but i would just be bored
yeah you know
to answer that question
women don't understand right that men
that men can have sex
with a woman
that's what pearl just said and not
having connections
yeah
i mean women can do it too but a thing
is just like but it's easier for men
though
i would say that what i mean
because we
we can detach ourselves from the act
because it's to a lot of men it's just
an act
why why is that
because
that's just how we're wired like we're
just wired different like we can have
sex with the like
[Music]
i know guys
that have had sex with a woman
and forgot that they even had sex with
her
do you know what i mean like is that
because it wasn't it was nice because
it was it was just that it was just the
act and so
they meet her and they're like
do i know you from
and she's like yeah you do and he's like
oh shh oh oh did we oh oh [ __ ] okay
because it's just an act but you know i
would say just like from personal
experiences that i've been able to
separate
physical and emotional as well right i
feel like just as easily as like any man
can
were you
what i'm not saying women
were you able to do that like right away
or did you kind of have to learn that
like i'm
like i was able to do it like first
first like
five-ish guys you slept with yeah like
you could detach yeah it was just like
you know like a night out okay you know
you just want to let go whatever you
just do it
yeah
i mean i feel like it's just like all
power to me you know i yeah
get
what i want without
what is it the luggage right yeah we've
got the baggage yes right
i can't
you know look at me without the baggage
right without the like you know oh like
what are you trying to do with this like
just like really just done what i'm done
no i get that but i just think that
generally
men have an
easier time
doing that like even in a relationship
because sometimes a lot of the time
there have been women there have been
married men men that have been in like
committed relationships and they've
quote unquote cheated with someone and
people like you you cheated with her
that's what we talked about last time
when you realize
when you realize you have to be worried
about the ugly girls too
like why
but the reason why it's her because her
face yeah it's like it wasn't because it
was just an act like they just it wasn't
because i was emotionally involved with
this woman or you know like
i just wanted to release yes yes you
wanted to [ __ ] and that's that was it
and so
yeah a lot of women
don't get that about men but i'm trying
to let them understand like men can just
have sex and just be out but my thing is
like i wouldn't ever want to do that
because like
what are the odds if you catch him doing
it once what are the odds that he's
going to stop and like how do you if
he's lying to you about that how can you
trust him about anything well that's
what i'm trying to talk about yeah lying
thing yeah yeah
that's why i talk about the lying thing
it's not about lying it's not being
honest but most people don't want to
have that honest conversation so like
i think
it'd be different if they were like say
like there's a man and a woman in a race
trip and like
they're an open relationship
i think it'd be fine if they were both
to like tell them like tell both of each
other like oh yeah i hooked up with this
person oh yeah like just not hiding
anything not hiding any of the details
because i have i do have like a friend
that are like they're married
or friends that are married and they do
have that relationship and it works very
well for them mm-hmm but so
i forget what like what my what point i
was going to make but i would say like
you know like i feel like that's so both
of them like the men and the women cheat
oh they go elsewhere so i would say so
they like
they go out together i've actually been
out together with them
like while they're like
on the prowl
not on the prowl but i mean just like
you know they're going they're both
looking for like hookups
that's like a swingers thing or
something not really i mean it's just
like they're going out and they're like
okay like i might find someone and they
both like tell each other like is this
okay is that okay
and then they just like you know they
there's a lot of communication i think
that's key to making that work i would
say 100 yeah and honestly yeah have you
ever seen 100 sorry no i was just going
to say would that be because you said
cheating would that be considered
cheating if they are both in an
agreement like no no no no no shooting i
would say is if
there's lying involved and then hooking
up behind the back there's not mine
involved if there's not lying involved
and you know
what like what do you mean
okay okay so
say that
i'm in a relationship and my dude's like
hey yo i'm gonna hang out at
my uh friend's house and he tells me who
the friend is the girl
but it doesn't give me
or
yeah it doesn't give me like full
details of what's going to happen is
that would you consider that line
like doesn't get if
like doesn't give you the full details
and then ends up hooking up with her i
would say that's cheating
yeah i would i wouldn't say that
cheating
but
like lying about going to her like not
saying that maybe his ex would be at a
party or something or like something
like that yeah do you oh do you think
that dancing on another guy
as a girl
is cheating so like grinding really no
it depends on like your partner's
culture as well like for example i'm
going to use carnival
for like what they like
their culture like i feel like if you're
going with the guy say you're not of the
same culture i'm not talking about
cultural dances i'm talking about like
grinding like anna got like a girl girl
goes back that's what she's talking
about oh is it the same thing okay okay
okay okay okay yeah that's integrated
have you ever example
yeah so for example say um